it's the blood composition that controls
the genes well then who or what controls
the chemistry of the blood i go the
brain whatever picture you have in your
mind the brain will translate that into
complementary chemistry and then release
it in the blood and then your cells will
conform to the picture in your mind if i
have a picture of love in my mind i
release wonderful chemistry into the
blood dopamine pleasure that's why you
always fall in love it feels so good and
most importantly when you're in love you
release what's called growth hormone
people in love glow they're healthy
they're vital they're vibrant fear
causes stress chemistry stress chemistry
shuts down growth less than one percent
of diseases even connected to genes
you can come with a normal gene but with
a picture that's skewed you can alter
the readout of the gene and make cancer
ninety percent of cancer is not even
genetically connected in the family
hello welcome to the pretty intense
podcast thank you so much for joining uh
you're in for a real treat today i've
been wanting to get this guy on the show
for a long time i have interviewed all
of his friends
uh joe dispenza greg braden austin
haramine
and he was like the final piece to this
puzzle of guys that are just thinking
outside the box and really educating us
on what is possible
based on quantum physics and the science
around biology that goes beyond the
quantifiable and into the
quantum and the epi which is just above
and so today's guest is bruce lipton
he's a doctor he originally was studying
stem cells and based on his discoveries
while studying stem cells and
how they interacted with their
environment and that changed the
expression which is the epigenetics
of the of the genes not meaning that the
genes change it's just the expression
the ones the ones used the ones active
it's just completely
reforming
our idea of what is possible and how
it's possible it was just as
enlightening as i imagined it to be
if you don't leave listening to this
interview with bruce with
two parts it's of the same hole though
don't forget is you're going to leave
empowered but you're also going to leave
with a level of accountability that
might be new to you so just know that
there's an empowering message here but
we're in control and uh and i think
that's the that's the exciting thing
about this conversation so please enjoy
if you like this podcast and um you're
enjoying what you hear and you're
fascinated this is the kind of stuff i'm
super into so you'll get more of them um
please hit subscribe also i'd love to
hear what you have to say in the
comments about this episode and i'll be
reading them so enjoy seriously i've
been wanting you on the show for so long
i feel like you know i've interviewed
many of your um
what did i call you like the three
amigos like
greg and joe yeah and then i just spent
a week with nasim i don't know if you
know nasa i know him very well of course
so i feel like you're like the final
piece of the puzzle and i've just been
waiting for this day and then when the
link didn't work i was like maybe the
universe no not want me to talk to bruce
i sat here saying i'll just wait it's
going to work and here we are
so thank you again and i i so appreciate
it because um you have a wonderful
audience out there
and the idea i appreciate it because i
think we have wonderful positive things
to offer them
uh and it makes my life so much easier
to have oh there's an audience there
how'd that happen cool okay yeah
you can talk about virtually anything
good i love that i love that you're up
for it and i think you're right though
there is a really important conversation
to be had one of the really big things
that i want to accomplish with this show
is to to wake people up to their
potential to what can really be within
their life and manifested in their
health and in their reality and
you my friend are like my godfather for
epigenetics
and i was just having a conversation
with somebody the other day and they
were talking about genetics and how it
can change them they're like no actually
it's just the gene expression i'm like
epigenetics so it's still your same
genes and so i think this is an
important conversation to have because
there's a lot of confusion but also so
much potential for what this could mean
within your reality so i think maybe
starting off by
explaining the relationship between
thoughts
and your reality
that we can do you just want me to just
go and i will go well i have seen that
before um i feel
nothing you say falls on deaf ears it's
all so important so whatever you feel go
for it i also have
dozen topics i'd like to cover but um
but just starting there like explaining
that relationship between the two
thoughts and reality
all right
um
let's go back to understanding how come
we're in a problem today in regard to we
feel like we're victims of our heredity
like what does that mean i say well
we've been programmed that the the genes
provide the character of our life and i
say well as far as you know did you pick
the genes that you have and the answer
is no
if you don't like the character can you
change the genes no
uh and then we tell you the genes turn
on and off by themselves which then all
of a sudden really makes you a victim
of your heredity oh my god there's
cancer running my family heart disease
or diabetes and and and then what does a
person take home with that message and
says oh my god i got the gene and then
their visualization process sees them
like i'm going to have this problem
well of course that's what i was
teaching in medical school for years and
then i i was um back i hate to say this
because it's dating me in the last
century uh back in you know 1960s late
six yes i'm that old back in the 60s uh
i was growing what are called stem cells
in tissue culture and stem cells are
embryonic cells
and all of us have stem cells if you're
out there listening to this program you
have stem cells for a very important
reason a body is not a single entity
it's made out of 50 trillion cells but
every day we lose hundreds of billions
100 i mean these are numbers that are
it's easy to say 100 billion i say start
to count to 100 billion it'll take you a
year or two to get there uh and i guess
so hundreds of billions of cells die
every day that's natural
the issue is well how long can you live
if hundreds of billions are dying every
day and the answer is well
every day we make new hundreds of
billions of cells i say from where and i
say stem cells and i say what are they
embryonic cells why don't i call them
embryonic accessible after you were born
you're no longer the embryo we change
the name same cell though
so i put these i have these
multi-potential cells i put one cell in
a petri dish by itself and it divides
every 10 or 12 hours so first there's 1
and 2 4 8 16 doubling at the end of a
week 30 000 cells in the petri dish most
important point they all came from the
same parent so i have 30 000 genetically
identical cells i split them into three
petri dishes
and so 10 000 in each but all dishes
genetically identical
and i then grow cells in what is called
culture medium this is the secret i said
what does culture mean it's a laboratory
version of blood
cells grow in blood
and i go okay so when i grow human cells
i say what's human blood made out of and
i make culture medium in a lab but since
i make culture medium i can change some
of the composition so i make three
different versions of culture medium but
three plates of identically genetical
you know genetic cells and uh in culture
medium a environment a
a cells form muscle
in another dish genetically identical
cells but a different environment b
different culture medium they form bone
and in the third petri dish again
genetically identical cells but
different environment the cells form fat
cells so i say well
what controls the fate of the cells yes
they were all genetically identical the
only thing that was different was the
chemistry of the culture medium and all
of a sudden this leads to a whole new
science genetics is a science of genes
control a disease or genes control a
character
this new science and this is really
critical is called epigenetics and i say
what does that be well epi means above
so we call skin
epidermis which means above the dermis
that's where the skin is so i said what
is epigenetic control that means control
above the genes well what do you mean i
thought genes turned on enough by
themselves i go no genes are blueprints
they're blueprints to make the proteins
of the body a hundred thousand different
like lego parts a hundred thousand
different pieces you assemble some it's
a muscle cell you take some of those
proteins assemble it as a brain cell uh
so i have a hundred thousand different
proteins okay
and the genes are blueprints and i say
well what's the relevance and simple
point it says to go into an architect's
office and she's working on a blueprint
ask her hey is your blueprint on or off
and she was looking to go
it's a blueprint there's not on and off
it's a blueprint like oh it's precisely
jeans are blueprints they cannot turn on
and off
but an architect can read the blueprints
and adjust the blueprints and i go well
what's the architect that controls my
genes
well here's the story we'll connect it
very quickly and that is this
i said i was putting blood
you know equivalent in the dish called
culture medium and growing the cells and
the culture medium composition changed
the fate of the cells and then i go when
you look in the mirror and see yourself
i go that's an illusion of a single
entity because each of us is made out of
about 50 trillion cells we are by
definition not a single entity we are a
community of 50 trillion cells those are
the living entities and i go so what i
go well inside under your skin you have
the original culture medium blood
and i go wait
the blood chemistry controlled the fate
of the cell cycle yeah it does in a
plastic dish but i say it does the same
thing in the skin comfort dish so all of
a sudden now i say is it your genes that
control your life and i go no it's the
blood composition that controls the
genes
now we take it there's two steps now one
step is well then who or what controls
the chemistry of the blood i go the
brain controls the chemistry of the
blood
and then comes the big one
so what chemistry should the brain be
putting into the blood and the answer is
whatever picture you have in your mind
the brain will translate that into
complementary chemistry and then release
it in the blood and then your cells will
conform to the picture in your mind
picture of health cool
fear disease not so cool but the point
about it was what the genes had no
decision making in this it has to do
with what are you thinking
consciousness is changing the chemistry
and the chemistry complements the
consciousness so if i have a picture of
love in my mind i release wonderful
chemistry into the blood dopamine
pleasure that's why we always fall in
love it feels so good i i said what else
you really oh oxytocin that bonds you to
the loved one and i said what else
vasopressin a chemical hormone that
makes you more attractive so your
partner stays with you longer and most
importantly when you're in love you
release what is called growth hormone
and growth hormone does exactly what it
says so i say so what's the relevance of
the chemical cocktail
derived from love and the answer is
vital very vital life people in love
glow they're healthy they're vital
they're vibrant i go is that what a
coincidence i say no
it's the chemistry
in the blood that is controlling the
genetics and the behavior
you say wait so if i have a picture of
fear i say do i release love chemistry
no no
fear has its own chemistry stress
hormones and things that regulate the
immune system so i say so what the
picture i'm holding
changes into chemistry the chemistry
then controls the genetics and the
behavior
fear causes stress chemistry stress
chemistry shuts down growth
uh and there's a reason let me give a
reason why the biggest issue on this
planet everyone says where's all the
illness coming from got healthcare
crisis everywhere i go
not from the genes less than one percent
less than one percent of diseases even
connected to genes
well then all of a sudden so where the
hell's all the disease coming from i go
the consciousness of the individual
is selecting the genes and as an
architect can alter the readout of the
genes you can come with a normal gene
but with a picture that's skewed
you can alter the readout of the gene
and make cancer 90 of cancer is not even
genetically connected in the family you
know that's a that's a hard thought for
a lot of people because it it but it's
an also extremely
powerful one because it means that
there's you have control but it's also a
really hard one because it means
you are the reason
and so
accountability i think is a is the word
that comes to mind with all of this i
bring this up and then i say well we are
creating this with our consciousness
what's going on and then people go back
over their life and they go
i created the cancer i created the
problem and of course the first thing in
the mind is going to go no i don't want
to take credit for that
i'm a victim
and now i need to and this is so
critical i'm glad you brought it up for
this reason
what happened in the past
was when you had no awareness of how
things worked
and the significance of that is um
yes you were involved with your cancer
but you had no knowledge of any
involvement and i go so why is this
relevant the answer is this
very important words you brought up such
as victim guilt shame
blame i go where do they come from well
those words
like uh guilt
guilt means i knew there was a right way
to do something but then i chose to not
do it that way now i'm guilty but if i
didn't know there was a right way to do
it then how the heck can i be guilty
nobody told me and all of a sudden i go
back and i say without knowledge your
behavior in the past was based on
not being aware
and therefore the concept of blame and
guilt shame victim all that does not
apply
it only applies to those people who knew
there was a right way and then chose to
do it a different way that was a
personal decision i would be guilty if i
knew i was doing something that was
wrong and continue to do it so let's
drop those words for the important
reason
what happened in the past without any
awareness how can you be responsible for
something you have no idea about right
okay
but
today now once we start talking about
this all of a sudden it says well wait a
minute
you are creating this
and you're creating this with your
consciousness and this is let me just
back up because that's the biology the
epigenetics mind
controls not just what genes are being
activated but mine can alter the
blueprint
i can make 3 000 different proteins from
the same blueprint just based on how i
see the world so all of a sudden it says
wow we are very powerful we're the
architects and we can create health but
we can also create disease because we're
the creator of it okay so now comes the
the big part and that is this
to me the most valid science on this
planet is quantum physics quantum
physics i say that because
uh back in 1927 when it was theoretical
they came up with a whole bunch of
things you know albert einstein max
planck heisenberg that came up with a
theory of how everything worked well
it's nearly 100 years and guess what
almost all of their theories are totally
accurate so
we have a deep deep understanding of
quantum physics
consciousness
is creating our life experience
principle number one it was back in 1927
max planck founder one of the founders
said the mind is the matrix of all
matter that's where the movie the matrix
comes from yes oh my god i love that i
just have to share like i was reading
this book called awareness and i had an
epiphany when i was reading it and it's
like you can get these sort of messages
like from the quantum field and the the
sentence i got was the mind is the
matrix well and so basically what's what
it's saying is the universe is made out
of energy but we shape it into a
material expression based on
consciousness so it says as you change
consciousness you change your life
experiences they go yeah this is
absolutely what's going on but the
relevance about all this is that that is
the principle number one and i say why
that is so important is you're not
living in an accident you're living in a
manifestation of consciousness okay uh
you creating this well a lot of people
as you just said well i wouldn't agree i
wouldn't create this
you know and i go
well here is why it works and it's not
based on genetics i mean look
you're a
an idol in the sports world you took
your life and you created
masterful consequences in your career
from from not just your driving even
from your wine
you are creating and manifesting all of
this okay i say oh where did you where'd
you get your driving skill and you go oh
like a lot of people say something in a
family like a child of a musician as a
musician a child of a race car driver
becomes a race car driver and you go oh
there must be a gene for that i don't
know it has nothing to do with it has to
do with what is called programming
and programming is very simple reason
why so let's give a reason so it's not
just new age
the brain is a computer an absolute
most advanced computer that humans would
ever recognize i go but it has all the
characteristics of a computer i go what
is that and i say in the old days you go
buy a new computer and you take it home
and you push start and it boots up the
screen lights up and i go oh good brand
new computer i said let's do something
let's make a drawing a spreadsheet write
an essay and you go no i can't do that i
see you've got a brand new computer see
not until i put programs into the
computer can i use that computer so
that's when you download all the
programs that give us the opportunity to
use the computer word and all the things
programs in the hard drive
but the keyboard is how you put data
into the computer
so the hard drive is the subconscious
mind it got programs in there
the conscious mind which is about 10 of
the brain right behind your forehead is
the creative mind
and i said that's the one that types on
the gay board and puts in what it wants
that's how you create your life okay so
i say well first of all where'd you get
the programs and the answer is this
when a child born uh
actually before it's born
the brain computer um
you know it boots up it's ready to go
but i need to put programs i said well
how do you get programs i say
it's an infant
i say you can't give it a book you can't
bring it in the classroom i say ah but
the universe
has created the first seven years of
your life that your brain is not
functioning at the higher vibrations
called consciousness it's just below
consciousness called theta
theta is imagination that's where
oh they pour nothing from the teapot
into the cup and then they drink nothing
and they say that's the greatest tea i
ever had mother says give me the broom
back and the kid's riding it because
it's a horse to that kid that's that's
not a broom it's a horse okay that's
imagination
data is that character of mixing real
world and imaginary so that's seven
years in the development of a child but
theta is hypnosis
that's a why zero i said how are you
gonna learn thousands of programs to be
a functional member of a family and a
functional member of a community i mean
just for example how a dad would talk to
you as a kid is not how your dad talks
to the neighbor's kids not how your dad
talks to your mom it's not how your dad
talks to the neighbor's mom it's not how
the dad talks to the policemen all of a
sudden say oh my god you gotta have a
lot of roles to play here how can an
infant get that and the answer is
theta is not just imagination's hypnosis
so basically a child just observes the
parents and siblings and community and
downloads like a video recorder the
behavior let's say we put wires on your
head and that's how they read your brain
activity okay
but there's all levels of activity by
and they refer to it as vibration like
how much vibration the lowest vibration
is delta that's sleep when you're in
delta the brain is idling like a car
just idling it's not going anywhere okay
but as you start to wake up the
vibration increases to a higher
vibration that's called theta
and theta is
characterized as imagination but
hypnosis
and then just above theta is alpha well
that vibration that higher vibrations
actual consciousness
and then there's even a higher one
called
and the next one's called beta which is
like school room thinking consciousness
and then you for example have even gone
to a higher vibration called gamma and
gamma is called peak performance
so there's all levels of vibration peak
performance is like a pilot flies a
plane on beta but lands a plane on gamma
because it takes more okay
you're in a you're driving your car
and at some point you're you're not just
a
in beta high focus you're in a high
performance called gamma okay so there's
all vibrations from the lowest sleep to
peak performance
a child's vibration brain if you put the
wires on their head and read their brain
activity for the first seven years is
primarily in theta which is mixing real
world and imaginary world and the tea
party or the
horse out of a broom and all that but
it's also hypnosis and i go so relevance
is this
how do you get your programs to be a
member of the family and the community i
said
just
watch
for seven years whatever you observe you
download now in your particular case of
course uh
you know your family weren't grocers
okay
you acquired
an understanding of this whole process
while you were an infant okay
and this sets your future
the first seven years of your program
is what controls the rest of your life
people go what do you mean i go the
jesuits have told people for 400 years
they said give me a child until it is 7
and i will show you the man i said what
does that mean it means whatever
programs that occur in the first seven
years during the download 95 of your
life is coming from those programs okay
well all of a sudden it says
hey what were my programs why my life is
controlled by them okay and i said why
and here comes there's a reason
and i say we say the mind but there are
two minds that
are interdependent they work with each
other but they learn in different ways
and they have different functions
so let's start with the the latest
evolution of the mind is right here
behind your forehead it's called the
prefrontal cortex that's the seat of
consciousness
consciousness is creativity the
conscious mind has your wishes your
desires what you want out of your life i
say tell me what you want from your life
and whatever answer you give me is
coming from the creative wishes desires
conscious mind i go great i said what's
the other mind go that's called the
subconscious mind well what's that
programs that's the hard drive that's
got the programs in it that you
downloaded okay
so i said fact that people don't
understand
the conscious mind yes it's creative it
can manifest all the wishes and desires
you want
but the conscience and this is it the
conscious mind can think and you go
what the hell does that mean
the conscious mind can look out your
eyes like you're driving a vehicle your
body is a vehicle and you're looking out
through the window
with your conscious mind and you're
driving according to what's going on
okay
but then i say but the conscious mind
can think you go so i kept thinking is
not looking out thinking is looking in a
thought is on the inside so if you are
thinking you're redirecting your
consciousness not looking out and
engaging in the world you are turning
your consciousness around looking inside
i go what if i'm driving the car and i
start thinking and i go
subconsciously this is critical
is autopilot
yeah in other words the moment conscious
lets go of a function driving the car
doing your job talking to somebody and
your conscious mind starts thinking
the subconscious programs become
autopilot they take over
so your life is not coming
from your wishes and desires when you're
thinking it's coming from the existing
programs yeah
i could be driving the car paying
attention then i could go into a thought
and i'm not paying attention
and and the car's still okay it's still
driving i didn't kill anybody
everything's really cool i go well who
the hell was driving the car when you
were thinking
trust me there were times where i was
driving the car and i was not thinking
about driving the car because the point
of it was as i was telling people is
like driving the car had to be second
nature at that speed you had to be okay
going 200 miles an hour without thinking
about it because you had to deal with
traffic you had to deal with how the car
felt what kind of changes you wanted and
so that had to become autopilot at 200
miles an hour absolutely because the
conscious mind is a very slow processor
what if i'm in the car driving and the
car and the car goes out of control and
i'm in my conscious mind well then it
would look like this
oh
because i'm too slow i can't make a
response but what happens is the moment
stress hormones come in they shut off
the conscious mind and then the
subconscious takes over that's the super
computer and all of a sudden you're
steering and hitting the pedals and
doing all that you know like faster than
you can think
yeah actually that's so good
at a great example would be driving into
the pits um and you have to make a pit
stop and there's like 10 things that you
have to do it's like clutch gear turn
this buttons neutral all kinds of
different things and i remember when
people would ask about they're like how
do you do it i'm like actually if i have
to think about it it's very confusing
but i naturally can do it i just can't
think about it habituation you learn by
doing it and once you learn it becomes a
habit then you don't have to think about
it i mean a lot a lot of people say well
that's subconscious with all the
programs like the you know like the
jesuits were saying control your life
for the average person up to 60 percent
of the downloaded programs they acquired
in that first seven years are
disempowering
self-sabotaging and limiting beliefs and
i say then if you are switching to the
subconscious 95
of the day that's how much the
subconscious drives a vehicle
95 of the day am i advancing my life i
go no you're playing programs that you
just sabotage your life and then you go
but i would see it and that's where they
say no you won't
because your conscious mind is not
paying attention when the subconscious
mind is taking over so the conscious
mind has no awareness of the behavior
that you just did while the subconscious
mind was in engaged okay i give the
example you have a friend you know your
friend's behavior very well and you
happen to know your friend's parent and
then one day you see your friend has the
same behavior and you wanna oh you gotta
tell you hey bill you're just like your
dad
back away from bill because i know
exactly what bill's going to say as soon
as you say i know what bill's going to
say he's going to say how can you
compare me to my dad i'm nothing like my
dad the audience laugh and i say you
want to know that's the most profound
story in the world i go what do you mean
i said everybody else can see bill's
behavior
who doesn't see it
bill
why why is that because he's thinking
and the behavior is playing therefore
he's not paying attention or there's no
consciousness of it there's no
conscience you're not using your cut you
know there's no awareness because
there's no thinking involved and the
thinking is what creates the awareness
no no no no it's the other it's the
other way around thinking is inside let
me just ask you a simple question what
are you doing on thursday presumably
it's not written in front of you right
now okay but i give you a minute and
then you can tell me exactly what you're
doing on thursday so where how'd you get
that information oh
i thought about it i go
well then you went inside
that's where thoughts are i said but the
moment you went inside you were not
paying attention to what was going on
outside that's when the subconscious
kicks in so
now you're driving uh pedestrian driving
uh driving they have somebody in the car
and they get involved with a great
discussion blah blah blah blah blah and
then at some point they look out the
window and they go
i haven't paid attention to the road for
the last five minutes
and now here comes the most important
question
what were you talking about oh we talked
about this and this and this
what was on the road
when you drove five minutes
i have no idea
i didn't see it i wasn't there why you
focused you were not looking out the
window you focused on the conversation
and i said this happens 95 of the day
that our driving our movement through
life whatever we're doing through life i
said what did you do you go
i didn't see it i wasn't there
so how can we if we are re before
programming the subconscious our
operating system yeah from the last
trimester through the first seven years
of our life
do we install programming later in life
are we able to actually are we only
correcting what i'm kind of getting at
is can we install bad programming later
absolutely okay
when did you learn how to drive when did
you learn how to drive not before seven
i presented oh ten yeah okay ah
so there's a different way of learning
there's the learning for the first seven
years which is hypnosis theta
but there's learning after age seven by
repetition practice habituation repeat
something repeat it and the more you
repeat it the less you actually have to
pay attention to it because now it's a
program you
when we were first getting in the car
when we were young oh the mirror is the
dashboard the gauges the engine sound
the wind what's going on so much
today you get in the car you put the key
and you don't pay attention to any of
those details they're automatic now
their habits so we acquire habits
after age seven through a process of
repetition now the problem here is well
you can have a good repetition a good
habit or you're gonna have a bad habit
you learn both either way but when you
once you have the habit it's out of your
consciousness
once you have a habit it's going to be
automatic and it's going to run it
because you're conscious 95 times not
even paying attention to what's going on
outside
uh and therefore we are as the jesuit
said
we're not creating the life we want
we're creating the life we got
programmed to create right right
exactly
and unfortunately in the world we live
in
we become disempowered by programming i
say why because people knew if i
disempower you then i'm more powerful
than you
that's how people got more powerful did
they get more powerful i say no they
were powerful already you were powerful
but no you were programmed not to be
powerful and so we are downloaded with
programs of limitation that take away
our power except for those
who don't go into that what are those
areas that deep that program us with
disempowered limiting beliefs like what
are those areas i'll give you the
biggest one
oh genes control my life oh
i am a victim of my genes so whatever
happens to me and i had nothing to do
with it the genes they go bad program
because epigenetics is the new program
that says no
your consciousness is adjusting your
genes you want to change your life
change your consciousness the moment you
change your consciousness you can create
a whole new life
kind of alluding to like news
you know television
um
that's kind of what i'm alluding to well
that that's the programming
you know
think about it this way you're driving
down the street and there's this family
having a wonderful picnic on the side of
the road they're all loving and they're
playing together and the family is
wonderful you go down the street but as
you go down the street there's an
accident on the other side of the road
guess what
you
rubberneck and you will focus on that so
you didn't focus on the good stuff you
focused on the scary stuff
because we have a program that's called
the biological imperative it's built
into every organism from bacteria all
the way up to humans i say what what is
that imperative
the drive to survive
a bacterium is built with a biological
imperative if you try and kill it it's
not going to go oh okay kill me no the
bacterium will do every maneuver
possible to stay alive so we are built
to survive
well to be able to survive you better be
careful of things that threaten you
so things that threaten you take more
interest
because i got to be uh these things
could threaten me so i look at the scary
things i didn't look at the good things
i'm okay with them and i got no problem
with that it's the things that scare me
that i pay more attention to and i go
consciousness is creating your reality
if you put a picture of fear
into your reality
then your biology behavior will manifest
things to be afraid of because
this is a short statement but to me it's
the most powerful one simple and short
it goes like this
the function of the mind
is to create coherence between your
beliefs
and your reality
if i have a negative belief the function
of my mind is to manifest behavior to
experience those negative realities
if i have positive beliefs then the
function of my mind is to manifest the
positive experience but we get
programmed with so many negative beliefs
and that takes our wire power because
we're not focusing on the beautiful
things we're focusing on the fear what
are you afraid of yeah
so how can we create awareness for what
we're not aware to what kind of
cues can we be looking for what kind of
situations in our life can we
become more familiar with to give us
this feedback this feedback loop of our
reality absolutely this this is the part
that all of a sudden i say well you got
programmed i say went from the last
trimester of pregnancy through age seven
so i said well what program did you get
before you were born you go i have no
idea what that program is i said what
programs you get from zero to one i go i
have no idea my consciousness wasn't
there how about from one to two no i
have no idea so i say most of the
programs you got you have no awareness
of these programs yeah i said well how
will i know what the programs are now
thank god i have an answer for you in
the answer
95 of your life is coming from the
programs your life is a printout of your
programs
okay and i go why is it relevant i say
the things you like that come into your
life that you love to do and all that
they come in because you have programs
to support those things okay but here's
the one that's important the things that
you wish for desire want in your life
and you have to work hard sweat over it
i'm putting a lot of effort in i'm gonna
make
why are you working so hard but the
answer is beautiful
because whatever that destination is
you don't have a program to support it
and you're trying to override a habit
that doesn't give you what you want by
putting more effort into it and i go
good idea
not good process why
ninety-five percent of your life is
coming from that program uh and five
percent from this little conscious mind
up here cannot mathematically if you
think about the subconscious a million
times more powerful programmer than the
conscious mind i say and you want to
right override the subconscious of
boy that's a [ __ ] that's not going to
work very well
and yet there are ways to do it because
if it didn't this is going to be a lousy
interview but
there are ways to rewrite it
and the idea about it is
if you understand the process
you can rewrite your life
and change the outcome you can change
these programs sometimes in 15 minutes
or less okay but you need to know how to
do it okay
the relevance about all this is um
uh the movie the matrix
uh is oh science fiction i go no no no
movie the matrix is a documentary what
do you mean i go premise everybody's
been programming go oh that's a given
we are all programmed from last
trimester to age seven everyone is
but in the movie they say well you can
take a red pill and get out of the
program
and i want to suggest that most people
in our audience right now that we have
here today have taken the red pill at
one time or another and their life
profoundly changed i go when was that
one of the best examples is when people
fall in love like what do you mean i go
well their life is blah blah blah blah
blah they fall in love they meet
somebody 24 hours later
oh life is so beautiful i'm so in love
i'm so happy look i'm glowing look i got
growth hormone in my system
i go
24 hours later after blah blah blah all
those years and 24 hours later you
manifest heaven on earth i got
how'd that happen and the answer is
beautiful
because the answer is when you fall in
love you stop thinking
you stay present it's called staying
mindful like what does that mean i say
when you're thinking is when the
subconscious
autopilot kicks in
if you're not thinking then the
conscious creative mind is the one
that's manifesting your life so
the moment you fell in love why would
you think and the reason is this you've
been waiting for this person your whole
life they showed up you want to think
and disconnect from this i go no you
want to stay present you want to be
mindful you want to be there i go you
stop thinking i said what's the result
it's the red pill
the moment you stop thinking is you're
not diverting to the subconscious
anymore you are operating from conscious
wishes and desires and so the honeymoon
is not an accident it's a manifestation
that says i'm not playing a program is
that like being in the flow
because you know when you think about
someone who's an artist and they're
creating a musician a chef a chef or
or in love like you're in the flow right
so you're just you're
you're not thinking yeah you're not
thinking you're doing and it doesn't
mean there's not participation it just
means that
you're not thinking of the future you're
kind of just
time and space sort of change like you
lose track of time there's that kind of
stuff yeah not thinking means not
diverting to the subconscious
meaning you stay in conscious creativity
yeah just creativity is wishes and
desires so
a chef
is so involved with the cooking and
paying attention all the details they're
not thinking and i say well what does
that mean they're not coming from
program they're coming from creativity
okay the artist the chef uh the race car
driver
yeah
not thinking man uh you know we're in it
we're going i had a monk tell me i
should write a book called the speed of
consciousness well that that's it
and the subconscious is much faster than
the conscious and that's why in times of
emergency
the conscious is too slow to help us and
that's why we jump to it but then the
problem is
whatever behavior you're going to
express while you're in that
subconscious was the program that you
had a positive or negative well up to 60
of the programs that you downloaded are
not positive
they're disempowered
absolutely
so what is it if we can take
consciousness a little further yeah what
is it that what is consciousness i know
this is like a we still don't have do we
have an answer for that even like why is
that
why is that the the mystery and and what
is that what allows us
what allows uh what what is
consciousness
consciousness is the experience between
a stimulus and a response i got a
stimulus
and i'm going to make a response input
output reflex okay
consciousness again in the middle i say
i got this stimulus i have a choice of
responses i can make different response
if i'm not conscious then its input
output just you know it's the machine
going this way so consciousness is the
freedom
to make uh a different a different
action
instead of just going input output input
output i got input let's think about it
oh i'd rather have a different output oh
well then that's your choice all of a
sudden but if you are programmed
subconscious doesn't have thinking it
says stimulus response program you're
going to repeat this your whole life you
know
the subconscious isn't evil of course
everyone thinks that's where all hell
comes from but the subconscious got some
great stuff in there like
when did you learn how to walk oh before
two how long can you walk you could be
102 you're still walking same damn
program you got when you were two years
old okay great program
but a negative program
will work that way for your whole life
but not give you the positive outcome
so uh the subconscious is a repository
of habits and then you can subdivide
those into habits that support who you
are
and unfortunately habits that undermine
who you are
and that's where the difference is and
that's why i'm saying so it's important
for us to know what your programs are a
lot of people want to go back in history
and say oh yeah this person did that my
mom did this my dad you know and
cry
waste of time
why
that's killing the messenger over the
message what does that mean i say you
learn something from that interaction
you carry the learning you don't have to
carry the interaction or the person
anymore you walked away with a program
so the idea is can i should i go back
and review and i go why you're just
going to replay the same old program
it's going to make you more upset than
before because you're going to replay
the same experience so i say this is a
beautiful part about changing your life
don't go backwards that's done you
walked away with a program what's your
program 95 percent of your life now i
can look at and say oh i'm having a
relationship program i go yeah like in
my particular case
i grew up in a family where my mother
and father i'm downloading their
behavior that's what kids do
and their relationship behavior is
nothing that i would want i didn't know
it then but for 40 years i couldn't get
a relationship off the ground why
because 95 of my behavior was observing
their action and then replaying it as me
and all of a sudden there was no
opportunity to get a relationship and
that was any good
because my program for relationships
sucked
i'm confused because my mom and dad have
been married for like 40 years and i'm
single so i don't know what i don't know
what the problem is and i'm 40 years old
so well you're a kid so don't worry
about it it took me 50 years before i
even figured out how to have a
relationship but i've done the last 30
of those years essentially living heaven
on earth why because
once i understood the nature of it i
said i don't want this behavior i can
see it i'm paying attention my life's
not working my relationships suck i
can't go into that i'm really curious
about the relationship part of it how
did that shift for you like what was the
what was the what was the new program
the first program the program came to a
head um i was living in the caribbean
teaching at a medical school which meant
i worked maybe two days a week at the
most which meant
five days a week i've got a beautiful
villa i got i'm on the coast and i
wonder why you're single i'm living
perfect you're living in heaven i was
living in heaven except
a newton partner i need a mate
i need somebody i need that was a
problem
and i remember
chatting up this woman who came in on a
yacht and i thought hey you're not doing
anything i got a nice villa you could
stay here for a while and i was you know
trying to use that line that i said
universe gave me the best line in the
world like i got a villa come on stay
over here uh uh and i offered this line
and she looked at me straight in the
face and she said i can't be with you
you're too needy
and it's sort of like boom
slapped me in the face but it woke me up
because
at the moment i was in shock but i also
then said thank you
because i walked away from that lunch
and i said you got more money in your
pocket than you ever had you live in the
most beautiful place in the world your
job is wonderful then you love it i say
and you can't be happy
with the things you got talking to
myself yeah i said
this is a turning point i said
stop looking for somebody right now
to me stop okay first if if you can't
enjoy
and appreciate all these positive things
that you have
then you can't look for a mate at this
time
and that's what i started to look at i
started let go and i started to say god
it's a beautiful day today i think i'm
gonna go snorkeling today oh it's a
beautiful day i'm gonna do this i'm
gonna make myself a wonderful meal and i
started getting into that what was the
point
i stopped the need
to have somebody i became self-satisfied
with my life that i didn't need anybody
guess what
the moment i didn't need anybody people
were showing up all over the place no no
it's okay i don't need anybody thank you
very much i'm okay over here i'm great
and this is how it really worked out
let me give you a fact um
we can test beliefs okay
and it's called muscle testing you go
what the hell is that i go
you have a conscious creative mind you
have a subconscious habit mine
the subconscious mind the big powerful
one is the one that controls muscles
okay
and then i say so what is muscle testing
i say here's the point you make a
statement with the conscious mind
and if it agrees with the program in the
subconscious mind then both minds are in
harmony and your muscles are strong
but if i make a statement my conscious
mind and my subconscious mind goes
through all the data and goes
that
that's not part of us then there's a
disconnect between the two minds and
that causes a weakening of the muscle
because the disharmony between
subconscious and conscious affects the
harmony of the subconscious control of
muscle then the muscles go weak so
you can identify a program by making a
statement and then identifying whether
the subconscious agrees but if my
muscles stay strong i got no problem
with it if i make a statement and my
subconscious mind doesn't agree my
muscles go weak and then all of a sudden
i say oh
that program is not true
at this time
so
interesting point just to bring it up
80 to 90 of every audience that i got
involved with with you know working with
the belief change programs
80 to 90 of every audience will not
test positive
for i love myself
and i go
well there's the biggest problem in the
world why if you don't love yourself how
can anybody else love you
somebody says they love you and you say
but i know i'm not lovable you must have
lousy quality control if you think you
love me and then we push people away and
then nobody's there and then we go see
nobody's here
it sort of confirms our confirms our our
our program
well yeah and i said well how come 80
and 90 of people do not love themselves
and the answer is this
in that first seven years
parents
act like coaches of a sports team and
raising their children and i said what
does that mean i go
a player on a sports team an older
player is not doing well the coach
doesn't go up oh please do better no the
coach comes up and says that's not good
enough who do you think you are you
don't deserve to be on this team well
the older child is conscious and aware
of oh the coach is saying that because
i'm not doing well i'm going to work
harder
that would be the the message but
parents don't recognize if the child is
under seven
and they say not good enough not lovable
enough not deserving whatever
a child under seven is not operating in
consciousness a child under seven is in
theta recording so i said well then what
did the child walk away with i'm not
good enough i'm not deserving i go
uh oh i say why well 95 of the person's
life is going to come from that program
i have a program i'm not deserving
my mind's job make coherence between the
program my reality 95 of the day it's
taking over subconscious it will
sabotage me so at the end of the day
it's like yep i guess i'm not deserving
i didn't get what i was thinking for so
i'm not deserving i know that was
because the program was not deserving
and you manifested it 95 of the day so
the issue is parents
criticize the children in the hopes as a
coach would criticize the team player
that the player would make a change and
do better parents do it with the idea
yeah i'll say this to my kid and they'll
do better and i go
under seven
nope that's not gonna work that explains
why i have the complex of not feeling
good enough because i came from sports
and i came from never being fast enough
never doing well enough you know you
didn't tune the carburetor right you
didn't do that and and it was a whole
bunch of you know not good enough
because actually
you know it was like even the
programming was like it wasn't a matter
of being the fastest it was being as
fast as i could be which meant that it
was never enough literally never fast
enough never good enough and that's a
that's a that's a rough programming it's
a rough program and also this is why how
could i get a relationship off the
ground if my programming was uh uh i'm
not lovable there was no way to get it
off the ground but half the marriages in
this
planet i said how come they fail you and
here's the cool part
when you meet somebody red pill
you're not thinking anymore you're
manifesting and i say oh when you first
cook up with somebody new
who are you wishes and desires that's my
mind who i want to be what i want
oh so two people come together
manifesting wishes and desires heaven on
earth okay
but there's a part where remember i said
you stay mindful you you weren't
thinking but down the road you start
thinking
and then your partner comes in and asks
you a very simple loving question but
you're now thinking
your response is not coming from wishes
desires creative mind it's coming from
habit mind right because that's the one
in control now because the thinking is
going in and it's distracting from the
flow and it's like the creative the
creative conscious mind is
is the one that you want to use but when
it's shut down thinking you go to the
subconscious program and then that would
be like my father's behavior and all of
a sudden what i sabotaged people but i
didn't see it why because i was thinking
and whatever came out uh it was the
problem people both partners in a
relationship understood the nature of
programs and separation of conscious and
subconscious
if a behavior the blah blah blah
behaviors comes up
uh generally what it leads to is an
argument between the one partner who
experienced the other person doing blah
blah blah and the one who did blah blah
blah not even knowing they did that and
then that leads to an argument and that
doesn't work but if both parties know
there are subconscious programs
then it doesn't have to be an argument
it can yeah discussion totally right you
can see them with compassion you can
that's the point because if you do that
then we can move to let's rewrite the
program
if it's an argument there's no rewriting
at this point that's just
exploded bad vibes whatever that's it
but if you knew that you had these
programs your partner knows you have the
programs and then you get into a
discussion so you want to change that
program i go yeah i go then why is that
relevant because if you clear out
the disempowering negative programs and
replace them with what the wishes and
desires that you on your conscious mind
and put those into the subconscious mind
beautiful point ready
95 of the day
you won't even have to be thinking about
it you will automatically be playing
behaviors to manifest heaven on earth
without you even thinking about it and
that's the cool part it's not going to
turn my brain off can you just turn it
off so is that would you say that that
beginning part of a relationship let's
say because we've all pro i'm sure i'm
guessing everyone in this that's
listening and we're watching has had an
experience or multiple experiences of
the initial phase of a relationship when
that initial phase comes that love is
there anything about that that's not
accurate in its indication for its
alignment with you and if it's the right
relationship or not meaning is that the
most authentic period of the
relationship or is there some sort of
disillusioned is there some kind of drug
situation going on in your brain that
makes you not see things clearly
yeah because look at this way you grew
up in an abusive relationship okay
abusive parents relating to each other
and then you gotta look for a
relationship
if it matches the pattern then it's like
oh yeah this is what my program i'm
happy i'm gonna get abused you know it's
not that they want that but it fits the
program so they find someone
unconsciously
who will fulfill that program of abuse
so their sadists and their masochists oh
they're perfectly matched and they come
together because they're going to
satisfy each other's program the
question is this do you want to be in
that program if you're getting abused
there's a moment that says
do i have to do this
most people in abusive relationships say
well it's better than going out and
not knowing anything i'll accept the
abuse i go oh my god you know this is
surrendering
to what you don't want
then you're that's the character of your
life it's you know look
interesting point years ago
um i would have been judged by
psychiatrists as manic depressive why
well i'm happy most of the time and then
when something starts to go wrong it
would be a spiral
it would start to go wrong a little at
the top and then it would get worse and
then it gets worse and then i'd get down
and get damn depressing at some point
because like i'd be talking to myself
not good enough who do you think you are
one day i was
caught into that
and i was alone and i was in the lab and
i was really messing up and i was
getting oh you're such an idiot
and i could feel this because i know it
could start okay and i'm and here's the
cool part while i'm starting this all of
a sudden there's a voice but there's
nobody else in the room i hear a voice
it's like out here i go the voice says
don't you have anything better to do
than to listen to that stuff
and i stopped for a second i go
sure i'd rather go see a movie than to
go through this stuff
so i picked up a newspaper picked out a
movie went to the movie guess what
number one depression a lot i left i
left it behind i shut off the story
chose to do something i wanted to do
rather than continue the story the next
time it started
a recall i started to laugh because i
remember the voice don't you have
anything better to do of course i do
after several times
i never have been in depression since
wow because the moment i would start the
new behavior was do something else
and so better hey i'm not manic
depressive i'm just manic
so what was that higher voice though
like what was that can and you're yes
okay most important thing is because i
came from science which we don't talk
about spirituality we talk about genes
life is controlled by all this stuff
in my research um
the research said no genes don't control
life
it's really the uh interpretation of the
environment by the cell membrane the
cell membrane membrane
is what controls genes
and as i was going through all this
research i recognized something very
critical i said i cannot put my cells
into your body because your immune
system would say these are not self and
get rid of it you can't put your cells
or organ into another person's body
because their immune system will say not
self and eliminate it well the first
thing you have to understand is
obviously there must be some kind of
self
that distinguishes us that our immune
system can even recognize who we are
yeah and it's at the surface of the
membrane
there are a set of protein antennas that
stick off the surface just like antennas
in the old days television antennas okay
and there's a group of they're called
self
receptors
receptor means receiver
self receptor receiver of cell
well in our conventional world oh it's
the proteins that make you different
you have self proteins i go no no the
proteins are receivers
of what a signal from where the
environment
and i say i receive a signal of my
identity different than you receive
because your cells are responding to a
different broadcast my cells respond to
the bruce show okay with the dana show i
go why is this significant i say your
receptors are tuned to a station a
broadcast an energy field uh and here's
a very important point
in physics the term energy is
characterized as fields okay energy
fields
the point about this is
no two people are receiving through
their receptors the same field and i
also then say well what's the definition
of the field this is going to make a
point right here definition of the field
invisible moving forces that influence
the physical world i go oh that's an
interesting definition you know why
what's the definition of spirit
invisible moving forces that influence
the physical world i go oh my god
quantum physics revealed to us we're not
this
we're the broadcast of the field the
field is who we are that plays through
this body
and i go oh my god and i said well the
first thing my whole life changed was
this i go well the body's like a
television set and the broadcast the
bruce show is playing on this tv right
now you're watching the brew show i said
but what if you're watching a tv and it
breaks i say tv's dead i go yup
is the broadcast still there the answer
of course it's still there just another
tv and plug it in you can see the
broadcast again i go oh
my god
we can't die we can't die we're not here
goes on
we're not in here we're the broadcast a
future embryo shows up with the same set
of receptors that you have on your cell
right now you are back with a different
tv and here comes important point it
doesn't have to be a male or female i
don't know that's the tv set how about
white brown black red yellow no that's a
tv set you're not the tv you're the
broadcast and all of a sudden i started
to realize oh my god i can't die i'm not
even in here
and then i had a joke with myself
because my joke was as a scientist i'm
like oh my god this is amazing and i
asked myself a question and this was a
most profound question i said to myself
because now i own the spirit
as a field okay and it was no devotion
it was like oh yep field that's it i'm a
field i got it
and
then so i asked myself this question
right after i got into that oh god i
asked a question
uh questions why have a body and a
spirit why not just be the spirit
and this is when i found i had jewish
cells jewish comedian cells i say why i
asked the question and the cells came
back with a question i asked why have
both this body and the spirit right now
just be the spirit and 50 trillion cells
welled up and asked me a question well
bruce if you're just a spirit what does
chocolate taste like
now
if you think about this the most
profound thing i ever heard by life
because it was what reason
well chocolate is because of the cells
that break down the vibrations of the
food and and all that and change it into
energy and the brain doesn't read
chocolate it reads vibration
okay what about sight i get oh pictures
vibrations yeah now
vibrations the body translates
your life experiences picked up by the
body receptors smell touch pain
temperature sound
all these things
are the result of a body analyzing the
environment and changing it into
vibration which then sends it back to
source
and i said oh my god
we came here in these bodies to
experience life
because our experiences are sent back to
our eternal source you have good
experiences and your eternal source is
in harmony and beautiful if a life that
gives you a lot of bad experiences you
can alter that source
and that's called karma
you've changed your source by sending
back signals that were not in harmony uh
and then we come back and we can correct
it we can come back and create that's
the loop that's the karmic loop is that
you keep coming back do you see it do
you see it do it
and if you get it right you how fast
does it take to clear up karma right
away so you understand what the hell
caused it it's like oh well then
change what you're sending back to
source
and that was the freedom moment that was
the moment that's a wait
i i'm i'm sending back my life
experiences that i'm manifesting if
these experiences suck i'm changing my
field and i don't want that and all of a
sudden that was the point i said then
change your consciousness
because that's what's going to send back
to the source and changing consciousness
says i don't want to do this anymore i
don't want to do that anymore why
they don't enhance my life they don't
hand we do it oh well we're socially
programmed to do this i i mean the first
step the first one was so
small and irrelevant in one sense but so
powerful was i'm working on this going
oh my god
i've been programmed and if i if i
follow the program it's a good program
great but if it's a bad program i'm
going downhill
and i remember i was in my office at the
university and one of my faculty
colleagues came in that day and said
okay bruce what are you bringing to the
faculty party on saturday night
i want to tell you faculty party might
as well just kill yourself you go there
and everybody's sitting around with a
drink not talking to each other because
they don't really like it
okay and i thought about that and i
thought i work all damn week
why should i go to a stupid faculty
party and waste the entire time where i
had freedom to create something i would
love to do
so on you know just came right out of my
mouth oh
i'm sorry i didn't realize it was this
weekend i have other plans i can oh i
can't i can't go this weekend i didn't
have plans but i just said that and he
looked at me like you're not going to
the faculty party i go no
and he walked out and the moment he
walked out i went oh crap i just got
saturday night for me i can do what i
want on saturday night and i started to
say what's next and it lined up
what can i get rid of that i've been
programmed that this is what we do
socially even though it takes away
character quality joy out of life and i
started to eliminate them
and say wait i'm creating this i don't
want to give up my creation because
socially this is what we should do
i said i got my life man i want to live
it and i have been living a heaven on
earth life
ever since those days why well with the
help of my partner margaret who i met at
50 so 40 years of kids age at 50 uh uh
and she
she was quite aware of all the stuff
that i talked about
we changed we rewrote our programs
beautiful we've been together what 26
years now oh my god honeymoon
every
day i wake up hey i'm still alive i've
got a great partner we have a great life
i work every day i wake up i was like
wow i'm still here i'm enjoying every
day that i can get it's called the
honeymoon effect
forever wow you do that i say
get rid of the programs that took the
joy away and replace them with programs
that give you joy got it simple that's
the feedback loop just look at your
feedback loop and go does this give me
joy does this not and if it doesn't move
forward that's the test okay i'm going
to take us on a quick left turn here
um
having studied genes and and and and
really you know know a lot about that
is there anything about our genetics
that
indicates that there has been
extraterrestrial
intervention at any point is there
anything about our genes or our dna that
is out of sorts
um
how did we get to this point
evolutionarily
yeah essentially leaping and bounding at
times okay
let's try let's put it this way let's
say a light receiving cell in your eye
can say the light is on or the light is
off that's all i can say it's black or
white it's either or okay
but let's say i have 10 cells that are
going to record light
and five or let's say six of them say oh
the light is on and four of them say the
light is not on
then i average them out and guess what
i see gray
what level of great well how much is
white and how much is black
and so the more cells that are involved
with making a decision the greater the
versatility of the response is going to
be
uh so if i only have one cell the light
is on the light is off i got 10 cells oh
i got a white black and a whole gradient
of gray in between
and so it turns out who are we well we
started with simple cells of just that
input output simple reflexes but if you
bring a whole lot of them together and
they work in harmony then they vote and
i say oh well then you have now a whole
versatile range of responses instead of
just on off let's say okay
and i say we start to acquire this
awareness
extraterrestrial
where's our spirit coming from where's
that field coming from it's not coming
from just this planet
it's coming from the sun
and the other planets
and then the concept
what about astrology echo it's
astrophysiology the fields around us are
influencing our behavior
so the the the part that becomes very
critical is yeah when the sun changes
its energy or planet which is like a
magnet gets in front of the sun and
focuses the energy differently that's
what magnets do and planets are magnets
focusing and expanding energy
we are responding to that
uh
and all of a sudden i said well then
your identity is not here your identity
is there everywhere you're here you're
connected to everything and all of a
sudden then that gives you the
versatility i can do this or i can do
that but it's a choice it's interesting
in um what's called esoteric astrology
uh it's astrology that recognizes before
you can do a prediction on somebody you
have to read their level of
consciousness what does that mean
the more con remember did we talked
about electrophysiology reading the
brain and then magneto encephalograph
where you can read your brain function
out here so your thoughts are going out
into the field shaping the world okay so
your thoughts are not contained in your
head i can read them out here with a
with magneto encephalograph you're like
a tuning fork okay
and you can generate any vibration you
want you're a generator of vibration
and
energy from an astrological point of
view is an energy in the field yeah what
i say
i can
make an energy that will enhance the
existing energy
but i can also make an energy that
cancels an existing energy
i go what does that mean i said then all
of a sudden
with more consciousness
your astrology is not predictable
anymore
because i can cancel an energy field
or i can take that field and make it
work even more powerful
because it's called constructive
destructive interference and physics
where one energy field can alter another
energy field and since we are
broadcasting energy fields i am not a
prisoner to environmental energy fields
because i can send out an energy to
cancel it or an energy to enhance it
it's also called bad vibes good vibes
and i can control that and all of a
sudden it says well yeah you're very
powerful but you have to be conscious if
you're unconscious you're totally
predictable by the astrology because the
field is going to override your ability
to to deal with that field
and so
it says yeah the less conscious you are
the more predictable you are the more
conscious you are
free will start to step in and then you
can create what you want irregardless of
what the field is saying
that's powerful
and all other organisms on this planet
are a manifestation of the existing
field
what day the swallows are going to go
back to capistrano it's not up to the
swallows it's up to the field one day
the turtles are going to come out on the
beach and perhaps the eggs and all that
that's on the field uh
and but when you get to humans
we have the ability to generate tuning
fork read the vibration out here to
generate energies that can enhance an
existing field or energies that can
cancel an existing field and all of a
sudden it says oh my god you're not
locked into the to the environment as
every other organism is you have free
will you can change the field
so you're changing the field from the
inside with your own biology but then
you can change it
on the outside as well based on what
comes to you
and i don't know you change it on the
outside because remember your thoughts
are not contained in here they're like a
broadcast
so whatever outside fields are coming in
my inside fields going back out can
enhance or or
neutralize an existing field
what what do you think about when you
when the news talks about artificial
intelligence the metaverse
[ __ ] out of you does it get you excited
what do you what do you worry irritates
the hell out of me
because i say why are you here
and because we're creators do i need a
machine to create for me
no i say look i get feelings i have
feelings when i'm in love
that's a great feeling can i be in love
through a metavision uh you know on a
screen i'm an icon on a screen oh yeah
my icon loves your icon big f deal on
that why
that's not
you're disconnected
the idea was to be connected
was to experience life
conclusion of everything that i learned
right up to here is this
we came here to experience life that's
what the body spirit the mind you know
what i said about the spirit and having
a body my my body
engages with my spirit okay so i'm i'm
connected at that point but i'm also
my spirit can direct my body it could
say go here go there do this so then my
creative not only am i sending
information back to my field
my field is sending information to me to
influence where i go and what i do
and i go oh my god
i stopped at that moment and i started
to laugh because i realized
so many people think when you die
you go to a place called heaven i go
you didn't understand we were born into
heaven
this is where we came to create
this is where we came to experience if
you lose the body and go out there you
have consciousness that's really great
i'm not saying it's not
but here's the opportunity to what to
manifest
make something do something experience
something if you then decide i'm going
to do it metavar metaverse i go well
then you wasted all these beautiful
receptors that were designed to to have
those wonderful experiences to manifest
them for real
more powerful they can do more please
heaven and yet for most people it's hell
i go is it hell because you can't you
know because it's the bad place i said
no it's hell because your program that
you got took away your creativity
and programmed you to be the victim
in a world that you're actually creating
so as a victim you can create a world of
being a victim
and the idea is yeah but if you're a
master then you can create the world of
being a master you are a great example
of it yeah i i you did driving then you
created uh the wine and then you had the
cosmetics or the candles and all that
other you know that all that stuff you
you took your mind and took it out and
made creativity
what is heaven what is it you want what
is heaven is a is a definition of what
you want i said do you have to die
to get what you want to say no matter of
fact it's easier to get what you want
when you're alive
because this is where you can do it so
the big joke is everyone's thinking oh
when i die i'm going to go to heaven and
i'm going jesus your whole miss the
experience man it was here is where you
created
are you creating heaven are you creating
hell that was a creation
and the idea is if you own it
like you've done like i've done like the
people that you've interviewed on your
program
they have taken over ownership of their
creation
and they're creating the life that they
want and most other people are saying oh
this is against me and my genes aren't
good and this world and bad and i'm a
victim
and i go
sorry folks
you missed the opportunity to create
next time you come back you'll figure it
out maybe
mic drop i love that that's my favorite
line i don't i don't i tell myself like
on a regular basis if there's a
difficult thing i say
i don't want to have to come back again
to learn this lesson i don't want to
have to come all the way to 39 again to
be in the same position i'm going to
learn the lesson this time
and you sent your lesson back because
your consciousness is connected to the
field and you have an input field and
the same field also takes the output
the one that sends you messages also
receives the messages so you are
creating
your your
karma
and i say well if you create in a very
positive way then i look forward to
coming back why because when i come back
i'm all set and maybe next time i won't
have to learn so damn much i can enjoy
this place even more
but i'm not giving up because once i
started to learn to create
and to enjoy
it doesn't mean everything i want
happens but it also means this if it
doesn't happen i don't care either
because i'll make something else
and the idea about it is freedom i i i
love to wake up
because when i'm awake it's when i get
to experience
that the joy of being alive most people
wake up and go oh crap i got to go to
work oh jesus
way to wake up well who wants to wake up
with that
why not just wake up with oh my god i'm
still here
maybe that's maybe that's one of the
ultimate barometers
as to whether or not
you have the life that you really want
or not is do you want to wake up are you
ready for the day are you excited about
the day
and if you're not
maybe i'm going to tell you you know if
i can get in here very briefly
there's there's something uh at the end
of the dna strands of your chromosomes
there's extra pieces of dna
they don't program anything they're just
like extra railroad track i say why i
said when you have a piece of dna well
let's use my arm as a piece of dna and
i'm copying it there's an enzyme like a
train
and as it goes down the dna it leaves
behind a copy of the existing dna but
then when it gets to the end of the line
it can't copy the piece it's sitting on
so
when this enzyme lets go the new copy is
only this big okay like that
and then next time it comes down you're
gonna go this far so the new copy is
this big every time you copy the dna
what's called a telomere
that extra track gets shorter and the
point is that's a degree of aging the
shorter your telomere the more aging you
do okay
so originally they thought oh the
telomeres are given length you're born
and therefore your life is determined to
go so long and then you run out of the
extra track because when you start
copying later if i cut off that extra
track the next copy is cutting into the
gene all that going to screw you up so
the extra track allows you to copy the
dna without interfering with the genes
i go so what and i said well that that's
the amount of telomeres that's your
light
and a woman elizabeth blackburn
discovered an enzyme
called telomerase i say what's that it
extends the
telomeres i say oh
if it extends the telomeres you get
longer life i go yeah
and i go
what is it that activates this enzyme
and it's so
important
because it's activated by gratitude
it's activated by service
meaning
if i have something to do i'm taking
care of somebody i can't go
i have to be here okay the enzyme makes
longer telomere because you have
something you're going to do a retired
person goes i am finished and the
telomeres go well then fine we don't
have to make any more telomeres that's
when people retire then they go downhill
because they shut off gratitude is the
one we said when you wake up and you
love this place yeah you are telling
yourself i want more
but if you wake up going oh crap i gotta
go do this and i gotta all this is
happening and this is negative and i say
you're telling yourself i don't want any
more and all of a sudden it says
our longevity
is based on the joy and gratitude that
we have
because that says i want more but it's
also based on are you doing something
if you're not doing anything then you're
really feedback saying i'm done
i got more to do and the system says oh
you got nothing more to do you don't
need any more telomere boom done gone
that feels very fractal it feels like
like the conscious creator that you are
is like creating
your fractal nature and whether or not
you
continue or not
your choice of words is very important
because fractals uh a lot of people
don't know about them but fractals are
geometry
uh and the universe that we live in the
material world and everything we live in
is based not on the geometry we learned
in school called euclidean geometry
triangles and squares and cubes and
spheres all those things what we did
it's fractal geometry and fractal
geometry is a repetitive equation that
repeats itself over and over and over
again and the significance is
once you solve the equation
and you make it again it just takes the
same story and makes it another level of
it so the idea is a human is a fractal
of a cell
a cell has all the behaviors that we
have in a single cell
but if you put 50 trillion of them
together we didn't get any new behaviors
but we got more power
in all the behaviors that we have so a
cell and a human same functions
present in both and humanity is a
collection of humans as cells into a
bigger structure so if you understand
how cells work then you understand how
humans work if you understand how humans
work then you are understanding the
principles of how humanity works and
this is where we're in a stage of
learning right now that says we better
damn well learn because we're so out of
harmony with the universe we're
destroying ourselves at this time and
the fractals are the beautiful part
because principle infraction this is it
as above
so below
the images repeat themselves at any
level of the organization if you
understand how one level works you
automatically have fundamental
information on how the other level works
if i know how a cell works i know how a
human works if i know how a human works
then i know how a collection of humans
work uh and so fractals are important
because
they're the pattern
that can get us out of the mess and into
the future well let's get along be in
community let's have coherence
that's it
you know let me close with something
because i'm not a religious person i'm a
spiritual person not a religious person
to me
religion is the business of spirit okay
so uh i say well
what does all this have have to do and i
say well i'm not much of a bible thumper
i don't really give a damn tell you the
truth but
i want to close with this because it's
so important
apparently the last words that jesus
said as in the crucifix crucifixion
was father forgive them they know not
what they do
i go that is the principle that we
should all be living by and i go why
because 95 percent of a person's life is
coming from the subconscious they have
no idea what the hell they're doing and
if you don't like this person because of
their behavior and we get mad at them i
say are you mad at them as a spiritual
entity are you mad at them in a program
i can
say okay you got a lousy program doesn't
mean i have to live with you but i know
that's not you it's your program so i
can forgive you but i don't have to be
here and live with your program and the
way it's working
and so the idea was
if people would forgive each other
for the indiscretions that occur among
them
by recognizing that was not the
intention of the spiritual entity
driving that person and was the
consequence of the program of that
person
you want to you know blame the person
for the program they didn't even know
they had the damn program
so the thing that we really have to
learn that will make peace in this world
is to forgive those people doesn't mean
you have to live with them if they want
to change the program then good come
back into the environment
but the idea about it is this those are
very critical words but it applies to
all of us
and it basically says
if we hold on to the grudges the anger
all that you know
energy that's not in good health for us
then we're not we're not surviving or
thriving
yeah we have to let go of that the
person wronged you
do i hate them
no i don't want to be with them
but i don't have to hate them people
here here's a little side thing there's
so many side things we go on for hours
but a side thing is that people think
love and hate are opposite like oh no
love and hate are
strange the same i say what do you mean
they're the same
because to hate somebody you have to
hold on to them
that's what hate love hold on to them
hey you still gotta hold on to them
because if they're not there you can't
hate them it's just like needing needing
is not having
that's it
and so
it's the opposite
of love is not hate it's fear
love brings you together fear separates
you yeah and uh we need to get rid of a
lot of that in our world yeah and it's
bring broadcast 24 7 on your local news
station
well i don't watch any of that
bruce you're brilliant you're such a
brilliant guy no i'm a lucky guy i'm a
lucky guy i was at the right place at
the right time uh and i have to say
i have what now 27 years of living a
life that i have programmed versus the
one that was programmed for me yeah
i don't want to die i'm loving this
place way too much so i'm going to stay
healthy and young as long as i can
keep those telomeres going you're going
to live to 140. i think you said that
that's not what it should be the average
thing and unfortunately uh most people
don't recognize this so why are we all
dying young another sidebar
is that we eat too much food
and the issue is what do you mean i go
you digest food to get your energy i go
digestion is burning food i go so what i
say when you burn fuel
you get byproducts that are toxic so
don't breathe the exhaust out of your
car okay it's toxic like when you eat
food
your byproducts are called free radicals
and these are charged ions that are like
bullets
that especially hit the nerve cells and
kill nerve cells and so it turns out the
more food we eat
the more self-destructive
holy crap that's why fasting's making a
huge run right now
breatharians ratharian nastin was a
breatharian for three years what the
[Music]
and the idea was because we always
thought we get our energy from the food
and it turns out ten percent of the
energy comes from food
percent comes from direct
energy transformation
in your body by something called melanin
the pigment granules in our skin
translate the energy of the environment
into biological fuel in the same analogy
as chlorophyll or chloroplasts in a
plant translates sun energy into
biological energy
melon and pigment granules translate
environmental energy into
biological energy that's why you don't
need to eat so much we can just i was
gonna go have lunch but you know but
that's for fun that was the whole idea
remember i said the senses give us these
pleasures
intermittent fasting we sort of
bridge the gap you have just both
of joy
and you stay and then you give yourself
a break
that was really good those were some
really good nuggets at the end i really
appreciate that
thank you all right thank you thank you
so much for letting me be with you on
this show i'm so grateful and i want to
thank your audience because
if there's going to be heaven on earth
it's it's up to all of us to work
ourselves yeah
old hippie statement you weren't there
but i can tell you the old hit me stay a
hippie statement is
take care of your own backyard before
you go out and save the world
take care of your own
life
live the best you can because then
you'll be a model
when you go outside that other people
want to do it like you did thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today i hope you enjoyed
it if you like what you heard today and
you want to hear more please click on
the subscribe button